you know what i didn't know about you
what is it
you were a a war hero weren't you in
world war ii
yes you were
and you saw horrible things in world war
ii i don't think people know about it i
couldn't stand it did it make you a
pacifist are you an you're an anti-war
guy i really dislike war right see to me
life is a gift
and you should enjoy it
i mean it's a great gift to be alive is
the best thing that could ever happen
how old were you when you went to war
i was 17 18. did you enlist
no
they drafted you right
and so you're a young guy had you
started singing at that point were you
having dreams of being a singer ever
since i was a little baby so when you
were this young boy and you wanted to
sing this war
going into the army interrupted your
life and interrupted this passion i
didn't look at it like that you know i
just
everybody had to go to war it was just
one of those things that was the most
horrible war it was the
studs circle in chicago call it the good
war yeah because it had to happen right
was it there was nobody to stop hitler
the the japanese were where's the worst
worst war philosophy in the world
was created there were you scared
yeah
and and and so the germans were
frightened we were frightened
nobody wanted to kill anybody when we
were on the line right but the weapons
were so strong
that it overcame us and everybody else
you were in the army yeah the corporal
and i had my voice i had my stripes
sliced from a bigot
captain in the army i think i know what
you're referring to when you were in the
army yes you had a friend in the army
who was black right and your sergeant
hated this
he hated a white man
it was a captain captain hated that you
were friendly with a black guy right and
he told you knock it off we were just
waiting for enough points to come home
at the end of the war right how long
were you in the army
uh
just a couple of years it was toward the
end of the war so this guy
you were kind of your best friend
was the greatest guy
he was a fantastic drummer and we used
to be in high school together we and we
met in manheim germany right in the
truman hotel it was thanksgiving
he took me to his baptist church
and i said well they they're allowing me
one guest in in the mannheim in in the
truman hotel in manheim why don't you
join me we'll have thanksgiving dinner
he said great and so we were having fun
the the captain came over he said
benedetto that's my family name right he
said get your
gear your your shipping out and they
sent me the graves registration digging
up bodies and from the you had to go to
the graves right i guess of americans
yes and dig up their graves and exhume
their bodies yes what was the point of
that to bring them home
no just to bury them just to bury them
and that's a horrible thing to see also
it's eliminated all bigotry from my life
as a result of that it's a premise in my
life that i think one of the most
ignorant things that could ever happen
are people that are bigger
bigoted about other people